This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a phrase from Shenzhen China that goes, Time is money, efficiency is life, and over the last 40 years, the city has wasted no time becoming one of the most productive manufacturing hubs in the world. But along with making 90% of the world's electronics, it's also a place that is known for producing lots of convincing high-end knockoffs. Not just sneakers, but imitation Yeezies.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。中国深圳有一句名言：时间就是金钱，效率就是生命。在过去的40年里，这座城市毫不耽搁地把自己变成了世界上最具生产力的制造中心之一。但除了生产全球90%的电子产品之外，它也是一个以生产大量逼真的高端山寨货而闻名的地方。不仅仅是运动鞋，还有高仿椰子鞋。
Not just purses, but counterfeit Gucci clutches. Producer Vivian Leigh. Shenzhen even has a mall that's famous for its faux versions of big designer brands. It's a popular destination for YouTubers to drop by and film ClickBady videos titled China's Fake Shopping Mauser, Shenzhen Fake Market Insanity! What is up? Good morning, we're at now in Shenzhen and we are on the way. Once again, to the fake market here, but first let's get a future. Hey guys, don't forget to smash that subscribe button.
不仅是钱包，还有山寨的古驰手包。制作人薇薇安·莱伊。深圳甚至还有一个以生产各大设计师品牌假货而闻名的大型商场。这是油管博主们经常顺道拜访并拍摄诸如《中国假货购物狂欢》、《深圳假市场太疯狂！》之类标题党视频的热门目的地。怎么回事？大家早上好，我们现在在深圳，正在路上。再次前往这里的假货市场，但首先让我们看个未来。嘿，伙计们，别忘了狠狠点赞订阅。
But there's a small neighborhood within Shenzhen that will have you second-guessing the line between fake and authentic. It's known for mass-producing copies of the most celebrated works of Western art. Monéis, mayonnaise, mateises, all painted by hand, all painted quickly, and all painted in one place. It's called Daven Village. I had heard about Daven Village and when I first heard about it I thought, of course, there's a village in China. That was completely uninterested because it
但在深圳，有一个小社区会让你对假货和正品的界限产生怀疑。它以批量生产西方艺术史上最著名作品的复制品而闻名。莫奈、马奈、马蒂斯，全部纯手工绘制，全部高效完成，而且都在同一个地方生产。它被称为大芬村。我听说过大芬村，当我第一次听说的时候，我想，中国当然有一个这样的村子。我当时完全不感兴趣，因为它
seemed so stereotypical. This is Winni Wong. She's an art historian and author of the book Van Gogh on Demand. China and the Ready Made. I used to take a lot of people through Daffin Village, and one time I was taking a woman from Hong Kong through it. And as we walk through, the first question she asked me was, which of these are the fakes? I thought, well, that's actually a very complex question. We typically think of the craft of oil painting as a slow, meticulous, even romantic process, but the piece is dramatically different in Daofeng.
看起来太模式化了。这是温妮·王。她是一位艺术史学家，也是《按需梵高：中国与现成品》一书的作者。我过去经常带很多人参观大芬村，有一次我带了一位香港女士参观。当我们走过时，她问我的第一个问题是，这些里面哪一个是假的？我想，嗯，这其实是一个非常复杂的问题。我们通常认为油画是一项缓慢、一丝不苟甚至浪漫的工艺，但在大芬，情况却大不相同。
At its height, 60% of the world's oil paintings were made in this point-four-square-kilometer village by Chinese workers. This type of manufacturing is called trade painting. Trade painting is not necessarily art with the capital A, it doesn't command the same kind of respect because it's made quickly and cheaply in order to sell as generic decor. There's a very good chance that you've been
在其鼎盛时期，全球60%的油画都是在这个占地0.4平方公里的村庄里由中国工人们制作的。这种类型的制造业被称为行画。行画不一定是带有大写A的艺术，它不享受同等的尊重，因为它是为了作为普通装饰品出售而快速且廉价地制作的。你很有可能
in the presence of a painting made in Daphne. Perhaps you passed when at the dentist's office or in the conference room of a Marriott in Orlando. You may have even hung one up in your home without even realizing it. Daphne is a place that's been vilified, romanticized, and analyzed since it came into the world's collective consciousness, specifically because of what it manufactures.
见过大芬生产的画作。也许你在牙科诊所或奥兰多万豪酒店的会议室里瞥见多它一眼。你甚至可能在自己家里挂过一幅，却根本没有意识到这一点。大芬这个地方自进入公众视野以来，一直被妖魔化、浪漫化和剖析，这主要是因为它的产品。
If you think about it, it's completely arbitrary. But it's arbitrary in that it's a product of Western culture. That oil painting means something, something different from a ceramic pot or an iPhone, right? We can imagine the mechanical processes involved in mass producing something like a lamp or exercise equipment. But what happens in Daffin feels entirely different, simply because the objects being mass produced are oil paintings. Prior to the 1980s, the city of Shen Zhen was mostly farmland.
如果你仔细想想，这完全是随意的。但这种随意性是西方文化产物的一种体现。油画意味着某种东西，这与陶罐或iPhone不同，对吧？我们可以想象批量生产像台灯或健身器材这类东西所涉及的机械化过程。但在大芬发生的事情感觉完全不同，仅仅是因为被大批量生产的物体是油画。在20世纪80年代之前，深圳市大部分地区都是农田。
And Daffin was just an ordinary rural rural village not really known for anything in particular. Let alone art. I have one photograph of it from probably 1970s and it is yeah just three two three rows of houses one taller we call it Dello and a a lot of fields. That's all. But Dafein's fate was very quickly transformed by a monumental moment in modern Chinese history, the creation of the Shenzhen special economic zone. There's a legend about the founding of Shenzhen. That in 1979, Chinese leader Deng Xiaoping drew a circle on the map by the South China Sea and determined that Shenzhen would be the home of China's first special economic zone.
而大芬只是一个普通的农村村庄，并没有什么特别出名的。更不用说艺术了。我有一张它大约70年代的照片，是的，它只有两三排房子，有一栋较高的，我们叫它围楼，还有一大片田野。仅此而已。但大芬的命运很快就被中国现代史上的一个划时代时刻——深圳经济特区的建立所改变。关于深圳的建立流传着一个传说。即在1979年，中国领导人邓小平在南海地图上画了一个圈，决定将深圳作为中国第一个经济特区。
It would be a controlled area where China could open up to the rest of the world and experiment with market capitalism by offering special tax benefits to encourage foreign investment. It was a modern neoliberal fairy tale that was even celebrated in song. This song actually called Story of Spring. It depicts the moment when Shen Zhen sprang forth from anonymity, mythically building a city that rose to the sky
这是一个受控区域，中国可以通过这里向世界其他地区开放，并通过提供税收优惠来鼓励外国投资，从而试验市场资本主义。这是一个现代的新自由主义童话，甚至在歌声中受到赞颂。这首歌实际上叫《春天的故事》。它描绘了深圳从默默无闻中崛起的那一刻，神话般地建造了一座直插云霄
and mountains of gold, as if by magic. But it was not. There are very good historical strategic reasons to place a special economic zone there. If you want to know more about SEC's, as you go back and listen to the previous episode of 99% invisible, the one right before this one, it involves a little airport in Ireland. I can't explain it here. Just listen to it. Okay.
和堆满金山的城市，仿佛有魔法一般。但事实并非如此。在那里设立经济特区有着非常充分的历史和战略原因。如果你想了解更多关于经济特区的信息，你可以回头听听上一期“99%隐形”，也就是紧挨着这一期前面的那一期，它涉及爱尔兰的一个小机场。我在这里无法解释。去听听就行了。好的。
Carry on. As Shenzhen rapidly transformed through the 1980s, businesses started moving there for the cheap real estate, inexpensive migrant labor, and low cost of living. Many of these businesses came from neighboring Hong Kong. Among all the first, enterprising business people to move into Shenzhen were Hong Kong businessmen, of course, because
继续。随着深圳在20世纪80年代的迅猛转型，企业开始因为廉价的房地产业、低廉的劳动力和低生活成本而迁往那里。其中许多企业来自邻近的香港。在所有第一批涌入深圳的企业家中，当然是香港商人，因为
they were right there. One of those early enterprising businessmen was a former painter named Huang Jiang. According to the plaques in Da Fan, in 1989, Huang Jiang traveled from Hong Kong and rented out a residential building in Da Fan, with intent to manufacture and export oil paintings. Wang Zhang recruited a team of 20 painters and began churning out hand-painted copies of Picasso's Van Gogh's Indivinches. Here he is in an interview explaining how he was able to divide the labor between many different painters.
他们就在那里。早期这些具有开拓精神的商人中，有一位是曾担任画家的黄江。根据大芬的铭牌记载，1989年，黄江从香港出发，在大芬租下了一栋住宅楼，意图生产和出口油画。黄江招募了一支由20名画家组成的团队，开始批量制作毕加索、梵高和达芬奇的手工复制品。在这里，他在接受采访时解释了他是如何在众多不同画家之间分工的。
I told them to paint as if they were on an assembly line, Some painted a sky, some painted the mountains, and others painted trees. When you divide it, the painting to different parts is easier for them to handle, especially for wholesale that really matters because otherwise you cannot finish the painting. This is June Wang, associate professor in the Department of Public Policy at the City University of Hong Kong. Huang Jiang and other entrepreneurial painting bosses focused on copying famous works of Western art, because any artist who had been dead for more than 50 years wasn't protected by Chinese copyright laws. But also, they were aiming to sell their products to businesses all over the world.
我告诉他们要像在流水线上一样作画，有人画天空，有人画山脉，还有人画树木。当你把它拆分时，将画作分成不同的部分对他们来说更容易处理，尤其是对于批量生产来说，这真的很重要，否则你无法完成这幅画。这是香港城市大学公共政策学系副教授王珺。黄江和其他有创业精神的画坊老板专注于复制西方艺术名作，因为任何去世超过50年的艺术家都不受中国著作权法的保护。但同时，他们的目标是将产品销往世界各地的企业。
Huang Jiang matters at a time in a leisure period because he has the connection to quite a lot of Hong Kong theaters. All around Hong Kong, hotels, financial centers, and airports were being built. And those brand new buildings needed to be decorated with lots of cheap, non-descript art. But really, those connections to Hong Kong were important because that was the gateway to businesses in the West.
黄江在休闲时期发挥了重要作用，因为他与很多香港剧院有着联系。整个香港的酒店、金融中心和机场都在建设中。而那些崭新的建筑需要用大量廉价、没有明显特征的艺术品来装饰。但实际上，这些与香港的联系非常重要，因为那是通往西方企业的门户。
Daphne's oil paintings were sold and exported to hotels, realistic developers and retailers like Kmart and Walmart. And painters were churning out wholesale orders just as quickly as the Western businesses were gobbling them up. It's actually pretty common for factory towns in mainland China to develop around a single type of production. There are areas that specialize in manufacturing only buttons, or jeans, or violins. And in this case, DaFen developed around manufacturing oil paintings.
大芬的油画被销售和出口到酒店、房地产开发商以及凯玛特和沃尔玛等零售商。画家们源源不断地生产着批发订单，速度之快，正如西方企业疯狂抢购的速度一样快。中国内地的工厂城镇围绕单一类型的生产发展起来，这其实很常见。有些地区专门生产纽扣、牛仔裤或小提琴。在这种情况下，大芬是围绕油画制造发展起来的。
When people came to DaFen in the first phase, it was really truly people with no education, like really people, rural people who had no outlet, but who had some aptitude and maybe their parents or cousin or friends said, hey, you're like painting, why don't you come and try this? If a person was looking for work and had a little bit of artistic ability, Daffin was the place to go. By the late 1990s, Daffin had millions of artworks, and the streets were becoming packed with painters, people stretching canvases, art supplies. Honestly, it's a little bit claustrophobic.
第一阶段来到大芬的人，真的完全是那些没有接受过教育的人，真的是那些没有出路但有一些天赋的农村人，也许他们的父母、表亲或朋友说，嘿，你喜欢画画，为什么不来试试这个呢？如果一个人在找工作并且有一点艺术才能，大芬就是该去的地方。到了20世纪90年代末，大芬拥有数百万件艺术品，街道上挤满了画家、拉画布的人、艺术用品。老实说，这里有点幽闭恐惧症。
You've never seen so many paintings. This is Philip Tanare, director and CEO of the UCCA Center for Contemporary Art. Streets and streets, you know, stores and stories that go on and go in. And, you know, there's just more than you could ever, thing you could ever see. And you could find all sorts of paintings in Dauphin. The most well-known were the replicas of famous works of Western art, the Mona Lisa, the Birth of Venus, etc. Then there was a smaller market for original
你从来没见过这么多的画作。这是UCCA尤伦斯当代艺术中心馆长兼CEO菲利普·蒂纳里。一条又一条街道，你知道，商店连着商店，无穷无尽。而且，你知道，这里的数量超乎你的想象，超过你见过的任何东西。你可以在大芬找到各种各样的画作。最著名的莫过于西方艺术名作的复制品，比如《蒙娜丽莎》、《维纳斯的诞生》等。然后是当地艺术家原创作品的较小市场
creations by local artists. You know, you had a wide variety of different kinds of production going on. There everything from a hotel decorator who would come in with an order for a few hundred canvases made to certain specs in terms of color and content. You could also commission a painter to copy any image. So if you had a picture of say, oh, I don't know, you're boss singing karaoke at a staff retreat, you could actually email that photo to a painter in Duffen
你知道，这里有各种各样不同类型的生产。这里什么都有，从拿着一份订单来找特定的颜色和内容规格的几百张画布的酒店装饰工。你也可以委托画家复制任何图像。所以如果你有一张照片，比如说，哦，我不知道，你的老板在员工静修时唱卡拉OK的照片，你其实可以把那张照片发电子邮件给大芬的一位画家
and they would send that image back to you as an oil painting on canvas. Sorry, what was that? Nothing. It's sort of an earlier moment of e-commerce, but very primitive. But I think that was kind of an interesting way of looking at how images moved and were transformed
他们就会把那个图像做成画布油画寄回给你。抱歉，那是什么？没什么。这有点像是电子商务的早期时刻，但非常原始。但我认为这是一种观察图像如何移动和转变的有趣方式
and this moment when they're transformed from digital and to physical and what that meant. Winni Wong spent a lot of time in Dafen, and actually a apprentice is a painter in a workshop. She found out that some artists are easier to copy than others. The easiest paintings than the lowest paid were van Gogh paintings.
以及当它们从数字转变为实体时的那一刻，以及这意味着什么。温妮·王在大芬度过了很多时间，实际上她曾在一家工坊里当过画家学徒。她发现有些艺术家比其他人更容易复制。最容易画、报酬也最低的是梵高的画作。
And van Gogh just can't catch a break. And then I learned that there was a progression. You go from van Gogh painting to impressionism, and then from impressionism eventually to sort of French academic painting. In the hardest and most highly regarded style would be neoclassical paintings. So let's say a David with the coronation of Josephine would be like, what you would paint to show that you're a really good painter.
而梵高就是走不出霉运。然后我了解到这里有一个进阶过程。你从画梵高开始，到印象派，然后再从印象派最终到某种法国学院派绘画。最难也是最受推崇的风格是新古典主义绘画。所以比方说大卫的《拿破仑加冕礼》，这就是你用来证明自己是一个真正优秀的画家的画作。
Repetition, a strong network of workers and efficiency, is how daffin painters were able to fulfill large wholesale orders. Wong says that the average painter could produce one to two paintings a day, but experienced workers could turn out much more. People would challenge themselves. One of my friends, he explained, he's like, I didn't believe it too when I started, but I came to specialize in fruit paintings. This particular friend was really competitive, so kept working at it until he could figure out some shortcuts to reduce a painting down to a few brushstrokes. And he said, finally, he reached the peak of 26 paintings a day,
重复、强大的工人网络和效率，是大芬画家能够完成大型批发订单的方式。王表示，普通画家一天可以产出一到两幅画，但经验丰富的工人可以产出更多。人们会挑战自己。我的一个朋友解释说，他刚开始时也不相信，但他后来专门画水果画。这位特定的朋友很有好胜心，所以他一直钻研，直到摸索出一些捷径，把一幅画精简到只需要几笔。他说，最后他达到了每天26幅画的巅峰，
and he did it by using a specific set of brushes that he would tailor in such a way that he could paint a grape with two stripes and an apple with three stripes. Right, so he developed essentially his own kind of repetitive method, his own specialized tools. Of course, not everyone was producing 26 paintings a day, but many painters could work very long and very tiring hours for not a lot of pay. But June Wong told me that, especially in the early years, most painters in Daphne came from rural farming backgrounds who didn't have a pathway to a career in the arts.
他是通过使用一套特定的画笔来实现的，他把这些画笔定制成可以用两笔画出一个葡萄，用三笔画出一个苹果。没错，他基本上开发出了一种属于他自己的重复方法，他自己的专用工具。当然，不是每个人都能一天画26幅画，但许多画家可以工作很长时间，非常劳累，却拿不到多少薪水。但王珺告诉我，尤其是在早期，大芬的大多数画家都出身于农村农民背景，原本没有通往艺术职业的途径。
Also, painting was a very different type of creative labor that pushed against stereotypes of what migrant workers could do. Because of the discrimination, migrant workers are very tired about this image. They are either on construction site or in the factories. So for many painter workers, they also take this as a success.
此外，画画是一种非常不同类型的创造性劳动，打破了人们对农民工所能做的事情的刻板印象。由于歧视，农民工对这种形象感到非常厌倦。他们要么在建筑工地，要么在工厂。因此，对于许多画家工人来说，他们也将此视为一种成功。
If you ask a thousand different painters from DaFen, whether they're happy, you will probably get a thousand different answers. Everyone has their own motivations for going there and what they ultimately want to do. DaFen painters probably would have continued quietly creating millions of the world's art replicas with little fanfare.
如果你问一千个不同的来自大芬的画家，他们是否快乐，你可能会得到一千个不同的答案。每个人都有自己的动机去那里以及他们最终想要做什么。大芬的画家们可能本会默默无闻地继续创作数百万幅世界艺术复制品。
But in the early 2000s, it happened to catch the attention of the government of Shenzhen. Shenzhen is trying to change its image, become more, you know, high-end. But Shenzhen doesn't really have that kind of base, especially if you talk about some culture, and although Shenzhen doesn't really have a long history, so for Chinese people, Shenzhen is the desert of culture. Wang says that Shenzhen had quickly become an epicenter for science and technology. But when it came to culture and social cohesion, the local government felt like it was behind,
但在2000年代初，它碰巧引起了深圳市政府的注意。深圳正试图改变其形象，变得更加高端。但深圳其实并没有那样的基础，特别是如果你谈论某种文化的话，尽管深圳确实没有悠久的历史，所以对中国人来说，深圳是文化沙漠。王说，深圳已经迅速成为科学技术的中心。但谈到文化和社会凝聚力时，地方政府觉得它落后了，
mostly because the city was still so new. The population of Shenzhen had exploded from around 59,000 people in 1980 to 7.7 million by the early 2000s, most of whom were migrant workers who came from all over the country with different local customs and even languages, and when it came to culture and the arts, leadership needed to start from scratch. This wasn't just unique to Shenzhen. A lot of areas of mainland China had undergone incredibly rapid urbanization.
主要是因为这座城市还太新。深圳的人口从1980年的约5.9万人激增到2000年代初的770万，其中绝大多数是来自全国各地、带着不同地方风俗甚至语言的农民工，而在文化和艺术方面，领导层需要从头开始。这不仅仅是深圳独有的。中国内地的许多地区都经历了极其迅速的城市化。
And by the early 2000s, the Chinese government was beginning to understand how fundamental cultural and creative industries like the arts or music were to urban and economic development. Science and technology parks were great for job creation, but they believed that if you wanted to foster a strong society, you needed things like museums, opera houses, and arts districts. In order to incubate creative development, the government decided to target
到2000年代初，中国政府开始认识到像艺术或音乐这样的文化和创意产业对城市和经济发展有多么基础性的重要性。科技园区对创造就业非常有利，但他们认为，如果你想培育一个强大的社会，你需要博物馆、歌剧院和艺术区之类东西。为了孵化创意发展，政府决定将目标锁定在
interesting regions of the country, like DaFan, and promote them as cultural hubs. This is something that happens pretty often in Chinese urban development. DaFan had distinguished itself as this place where painting happens. And then what's the next step? Can you make it into a cultural hub? Can you make it into an art district?
国内有趣的地区，比如大芬，并将它们推广为文化中心。这在中国城市发展中是很常见的事情。大芬已经将自己塑造成了一个进行绘画的地方。那么下一步是什么？你能把它打造成一个文化中心吗？你能把它变成一个艺术区吗？
Can you build a museum? Can you attract tourists? Where do you go from there? However, the government wanted to lean away from the image of fake masterpieces because to them, Replicating Art was not the same thing as creating art. They didn't want Daven to settle for being a copy village
你能建一座博物馆吗？你能吸引游客吗？从那里你可以去哪里？然而，政府希望摆脱假名作的形象，因为对他们来说，复制艺术不等同于创造艺术。他们不希望大芬满足于做一个盗版村
when it could be a center for original art and creativity. So the goal was to transform Daven from a copycat village into a legitimate artist district starting with its urban development. They did, you know, fix the sewage, you know, beautify the sidewalks, you know, they did do these things
当它可以成为原创艺术和创意的中心时。因此，目标是从城市开发开始，将大芬从一个山寨村转化为一个合法的艺术家聚居区。你知道，他们确实整修了污水管道，美化了人行道，你知道，他们确实做了这些事情
that one would expect a good government to do. The local government paved the roads and updated housing. They also formed artists associations who stood cultural fairs and offered incentives to attract art school educated artists in order to bolster Daphne's art cred. The propaganda department even got involved
这是一个好政府理应做的事。地方政府铺设了道路并更新了住房。他们还成立了艺术家协会，举办文化博览会，并提供激励措施来吸引艺术院校毕业的艺术家，以提升大芬的艺术信誉。宣传部甚至介入其中
to come up with more inventive ways to elevate Daphne's reputation. They hired a novelist to write a novel. There was a movie. There were songs they made a television series. There were actually multiple television series based in Daven, like this show called The Fate of Painting, about a woman who comes to a Daven-like village
想出更多有创意的方法来提升大芬的声誉。他们聘请了一位小说家来写一部小说。有一部电影。有歌曲，他们制作了一部电视剧。实际上有几部以大芬为背景的电视剧，比如这部名为《画之缘》的剧集，讲述了一个来到大芬这样的村庄寻找疏远父亲的女性，却面临着秘密、浪漫和艺术的故事。地方政府甚至煞费苦心地解决大芬的侵权问题。
to find her strange father, but is confronted by secrets, romance and art. The local government even took pains to address concerns of copyright infringement in daffan. They handed out copyright law books. They held like sessions on copyright infringement, right? They were concerned about this narrative that they were a copyright infringers and they wanted to promote creativity originality.
他们分发著作权法书籍。他们举办了关于侵权问题的讲座，对吧？他们担心他们作为侵权者的这种叙事，他们希望推广创意和原创性。
But as Daphne's profile rose, it didn't just gain the attention of the local government or artists, it was also starting to catch the attention of the rest of the world. Around the same time that Daphne was undergoing this government-led culture project, Western media outlets were beginning to catch wind of this small village in China that pumped out hand-painted revocas of Western works of art. The West had been buying these paintings for years, but most people were just now beginning to understand where they came from and who was making them. In the beginning, the international coverage was the opposite of what leadership was going for.
但随着大芬知名度的提升，它不仅吸引了地方政府和艺术家的注意，也开始吸引世界其他地方的注意。在大芬经历这个政府主导的文化项目的同时，西方媒体开始注意到中国这个小村庄，这里源源不断地生产着西方艺术品的纯手工复制品。西方购买这些画作已经很多年了，但大多数人直到现在才开始了解它们来自哪里以及是谁制作的。起初，国际报道与领导层的目标截然相反。
A lot of news coverage focused on the image of an army of factory workers, slaving away to pump out counterfeit paintings into the art market. There were headlines like own original Chinese coffees of real Western art and Van Gogh from the sweatshop. There was a New York Times story early on
许多新闻报道都聚焦于这样一种形象：成群结队的工厂工人辛勤劳作，向艺术市场倾销山寨画作。当时出现了这样的头条新闻：《正宗西方艺术的中国山寨货》以及《血汗工厂里的梵高》。早期有一篇《纽约时报》的报道
and I think it confirmed a lot of prejudices people had about China at that moment as a place where things were being knocked off and copied. And you know, what's the highest level of knock off and copying? It's forging art. Here's Philip Tanari from the UCCA again. This is the moment of fake DVDs and counterfeit products and IP theft. So it was also easy to come at it from a lens. If here they are copying this person or that person in a kind of a parodical way where it wasn't.
我认为它证实了人们当时对中国的大量成见，认为这是一个充斥着山寨和复制品的地方。你知道，山寨和复制的最高级别是什么？那就是伪造艺术。这里又是来自UCCA的菲利普·蒂纳里。这是盗版光盘、假冒产品和知识产权盗窃的时代。所以从这个角度来看也很容易理解。如果他们以一种讽刺的方式模仿这个人或那个人，而事实并非如此。
I'm not sure that was essentially what was going on. At the time, Duffen was being swept up in a larger debates about China's place on the global stage. What was happening in Duffin was a complex intermingling of migrant labor, craft, local policy, and globalism. It was reduced into yet another story about how the West was the source of authenticity, and China was ripping it off.
我不确定这是否真的是当时发生的事情。当时，大芬被卷入了关于中国在全球舞台上地位的更大争论中。大芬发生的事情是农民工劳动力、工艺、地方政策和全球化的一种复杂交织。它被简化成了又一个关于西方是真实性的源头而中国在剽窃它的故事。
Ironically, Duffin painters were being criticized for fulfilling a market that was created by the very people who demanded these paintings. Of course, art forgery can and does happen in China, but it also happens everywhere. Plus, no one believed that the 30-dollar painting they ordered from Shenzhen was an original Gustav Klimt. These paintings were not intended to sit in a gallery or museum. They were meant to spruce up the wall of a conference room. By 2008, Daphne had undergone its urban makeover, and it even formally changed its name to Daphne Oil Painting Village, but it was never quite able to shake its image as the copy capital of the world.
具有讽刺意味的是，大芬的画家们因为满足了一个由那些要求这些画作的人所创造的市场而受到批评。当然，艺术造假可以而且确实发生在中国，但它在任何地方也都存在。另外，没有人会相信他们从深圳订购的30美元的画作是古斯塔夫·克里姆特的真迹。这些画作并不是为了放在画廊或博物馆里欣赏的。它们是为了点缀会议室的墙壁。到2008年，大芬已经完成了城市大改造，甚至正式更名为大芬油画村，但它始终无法完全摆脱世界山寨之都的形象。
It is very successful, a very well-known in terms of high concentration of painters, but at the same time, Daphne is always hunted by this image of a copy. It might not have become the bastion for, quote, original art, but the streets were cleaner. There was a lot more creative energy in the air and the industry was booming. At least it was until... This is going to be one of the watershed days in financial markets history. It was a manic Monday in the financial markets.
它非常成功，在高度密集的画家方面非常知名，但与此同时，大芬始终被这种山寨的形象所困扰。它可能没有成为所谓“原创艺术”的堡垒，但街道变得更干净了。空气中弥漫着更多的创作活力，行业正在蓬勃发展。至少在……之前是这样。这将是金融市场历史上具有分水岭意义的日子之一。这是金融市场上疯狂的星期一。
The Dow tumbled more than 500 points after two pillars of the street tumbled over the weekend. In 2008, the global financial crisis rocked Wall Street and reverberated throughout the rest of the world, even reaching the small painting village of Daven. Before 2008, around 80% of the paintings made in Daven were exported to the West. But the financial crisis had a severe impact on real estate development all over the world.
在华尔街两大支柱在周末倒塌后，道琼斯指数暴跌了500多点。2008年，全球金融危机震撼了华尔街，并在世界各地产生回响，甚至波及了大芬这个小小的绘画村。2008年之前，大芬制作的画作中约有80%出口到西方。但金融危机对世界各地的房地产开发造成了严重打击。
Fewer construction projects meant that there were fewer blank walls that required cheap, unobjectionable decoration. Sales in Daven plummeted by 50%. You know, by 2015, it was very, very quiet in DaFen. And a quiet, meaning there was a lot less business. But even though business dropped a lot for DaFen, it didn't disappear completely. With a Chinese real estate boom
建筑项目减少意味着需要廉价、无可挑剔的装饰的空白墙壁也减少了。大芬的销量暴跌了50%。你知道，到2015年，大芬变得非常非常安静。安静意味着业务少了很多。但尽管大芬的业务大幅下降，它并没有完全消失。随着中国房地产的蓬勃发展
and with a rising middle class within the country, DaFen had a new Chinese market to tap into, which meant that there were different artistic styles to cater to. I know a while back the famous, like, Van Gogh and the Mona Lisa, and those used to be popular, that's not so popular anymore. Um, just a few customers by these kind of paintings. Most of the customers buy more than art.
随着国内中产阶级的崛起，大芬有了一个新的中国市场可以开拓，这意味着需要迎合不同的艺术风格。我知道前段时间著名的梵高和蒙娜丽莎曾经很受欢迎，现在已经不太受欢迎了。嗯，只有少数客户买这种画。大多数客户购买的不仅仅是艺术品。
And I'm very, very popular, very beautiful images. This is Chris Schur. He's the owner of a painting company called Shenzhen Melga Art that's been based in Daphne since 2017. He says that those replicas of classical Western art that put Daphne on the map aren't really invoked anymore. His buyers want modern, abstract, and original paintings. In recent years, things have been more challenging in DaFen.
而且我非常非常受欢迎，是非常美丽的图像。这是克里斯·舒尔。他是深圳美加艺术画廊的老板，这家画廊自2017年以来一直立足于大芬。他说，当年让大芬名声大噪的西方古典艺术复制品已经不再吃香了。他的买家想要现代、抽象和原创的画作。近年来，大芬的日子更具挑战性。
Business never fully recovered after the 2008 financial crisis, and a lot of painters and bosses have moved out of the area because gentrification made it a less affordable place to live. The internet has made it possible to work from anywhere, so people have been moving to places with lower costs of living. There isn't as much reason to have a centralized painting industry anymore. The stores, the stores in Daven Village, their business become worse and worse. Coming into reporting this, I thought that the type of labor that was happening in Daven was wholly different from fine art.
2008年金融危机后，业务从未完全恢复，由于中产阶级化使得这里不再是一个负担得起的生活场所，许多画家和老板已经搬离了这个地区。互联网使得在任何地方工作成为可能，因此人们一直在向生活成本较低的地方搬迁。不再有那么多理由拥有一个集中的绘画行业了。大芬村的店铺，他们的生意变得越来越差。在进行这次报道之前，我认为大芬发生的劳动力类型与纯艺术完全不同。
But I'm not so sure anymore. The truth is that the distinction between mass production and individual artistry has always been blurry. Artists all over the world like Jeff Coons have quietly used laborers and fabricators in order to execute their grand ideas. Daffin painters actually let us in on that process and show us that relationship in an unambiguous way.
但我不再那么确定了。事实是，大规模生产与个人艺术之间的界限一直都很模糊。世界各地的艺术家，如杰夫·昆斯，一直在默默地使用工人和制造者来执行他们的宏大构想。大芬的画家实际上让我们得以一窥这一过程，并以一种毫不含糊的方式向我们展示了这种关系。
You could look at Damien Hurst or Coons and say, well, that's what they're doing. You know, we're going back to Warhol and the factory. We're really overseeing a project. You're sort of the architect of the project, but the labor is being done by multiple people or in multiple places or in multiple stages. This is Eddie Cola. He's a mixed media artist who spoke to me from beautiful, noisy East Oakland, California. A lot of notable artists have actually used Dauphin painters, sort of like ghost writers.
你可以看看达明·赫斯特或昆斯，然后说，好吧，这就是他们在做的。你知道，我们正在回到沃霍尔和工厂。你实际上是在监督一个项目。你有点像是这个项目的建筑师，但劳动力是由多个人、在多个地方或多个阶段完成的。这是埃迪·科拉。他是一位混合媒介艺术家，他在美丽而喧闹的加利福尼亚州奥克兰接受了我的采访。许多知名艺术家实际上都使用过大芬的画家，有点像代笔人。
They come up with the concept and then outsource the labor to Dauphin in order to execute their ideas because it's efficient. And Eddie thinks that there's actually something creative and undervalued happening in the mass manufacturing of oil paintings at places like Daven. He decided to blur the line between production and art even further by incorporating the Daven copying process into his artwork. I mean, part of the reason I want to go back to Daven
他们想出概念，然后将劳动力外包给大芬来执行他们的想法，因为这很有效率。埃迪认为，在大芬这样地方的大规模油画制造中，实际上发生了一些有创造力且被低估的事情。他通过将大芬的复制过程融入到他的艺术作品中，进一步模糊了生产和艺术之间的界限。我的意思是，我想回到大芬的部分原因
is because there's so many possibilities about what you could do as an artist. Eddie visited Daphne back in 2018 while he was doing an artist's residency based in Shenzhen. And while he was there, he decided to conduct a bit of an artistic experiment. He had a graphic that he had designed. It was an image of a woman staring straight forward, sort of like in a passport photo. Aside from some red text running down the sides, it's a pretty monochromatic image, kind of like something from an edgy graphic
是因为作为一名艺术家，你能做什么有太多的可能性了。埃迪在2018年访问了大芬，当时他在深圳进行驻留艺术家的项目。当他在那里时，他决定进行一点艺术实验。他有一个自己设计的图形。那是一个直视前方的女性形象，有点像护照照片。除了两侧有一些红色文字外，它是一个相当单色的图像，有点像前卫漫画小说里的东西。
novel. He chose a Duffen painter randomly and asked him to copy the graphic as an oil painting. About a week later, he got a message that the painting was ready. Then he repeated the process, asking another painter to make a copy of that copy. ready. Then you repeated the process, asking another painter to make a copy of that copy. I went to pick it up and then just basically walked 20 or 30 feet down the street and handed the second painter the first copy. So can you copy this? Please, like sure. He did this every week for seven weeks, each time bringing the newest copy of the copy of the image until he was left with six different paintings that all built upon the last version.
他随机选择了一位大芬画家，请他将这个图形复制成油画。大约一周后，他收到消息说画作准备好了。然后他重复这个过程，请另一位画家制作该复制品的复制品。准备好了。然后他重复这个过程，请另一位画家制作该复制品的复制品。我去取了画，然后基本上沿着街道走了20或30英尺，把第一幅复制品交给了第二位画家。所以你能复制这个吗？当然可以。他连续七周每周都这样做，每次都带来该图像复制品的最新复制品，直到他手里剩下六幅截然不同、每一幅都在前一个版本上构建的画作。
And so the whole point of the process was, how does the idea of copying something over and over again change? And it does, like the last painting compared to the original painting are completely different. By the six painting, the image had changed in a ton of obvious and beautiful ways. While the first painting was muted in somber, the six painting was exploding with color. The subject of the painting even looks like a different person.
所以整个过程的重点是，一遍又一遍地复制某事物的想法是如何变化的。确实如此，比如最后一幅画与原画相比完全不同。到了第六幅画，图像已经以大量明显而美丽的方式发生了变化。虽然第一幅画显得柔和阴郁，但第六幅画却色彩爆炸。画中的主体甚至看起来像另一个人。
One thing that's overlooked about oil paintings produced in Daphne is that they're not exact copies. Every painting is actually unique because it is done by hand. We just tend to focus on the similarities and not the differences. Eddie sees this project as a reflection of greater shenzhen, a place that's been criticized by the West for copycat culture. When in fact, copying is an essential part of the artistic process
关于大芬出产的油画，有一个被忽视的事实是，它们不是完全相同的复制品。每幅画其实都是独一无二的，因为它是手工完成的。我们往往只关注它们的相似之处，而不是不同之处。埃迪将这个项目视为对更大视野下深圳的反映，这是一个因山寨文化而受到西方批评的地方。但事实上，复制是艺术过程的一个重要部分，或者说对于任何学习过程而言都是如此。
or really any learning process for that matter. In his interpretation, the quote, real art can exist without the quote, fake art. We always start copying. In fact, I mean, that's how all knowledge really works. If you learn to play an instrument, they teach you how to play existing songs. They don't say, well, write an original composition. And so I think that's exactly the way all things evolve. Duffen Labor has been used in a lot of different ways.
在他的解读中，“真正的艺术”可以没有“虚假的艺术”而存在。我们总是从复制开始。事实上，我的意思是，这就是所有知识的真正运作方式。如果你学习演奏乐器，他们会教你如何演奏现有的歌曲。他们不会说，去写一首原创作品吧。所以我认为这正是所有事物进化的方式。大芬的劳动力曾被以许多不同的方式使用。
I don't hold on to it. When the West demanded affordable masterpieces, Duffen painters made them. When China wanted original works of art, Duffen created them. When professional artists needed skilled labor, DaFen supplied it. Okay, so I have this package from China.
我对此并不执着。当西方需要价格实惠的名作时，大芬的画家们创作了它们。当中国需要原创艺术品时，大芬创造了它们。当专业艺术家需要熟练劳动力时，大芬供应了它。好了，所以我收到了来自中国的这个包裹。
It's about two and a half feet by one and a half feet. To Rowan Mars. And when I reached out to a painting company in DaFen, and asked them to create something truly absurd. This is the picture of me holding a microphone. Which was an oil painting of my boss doing karaoke at a staff retreat. They really delivered. And honestly, it was worth every penny. Now that is art right there.
大约两英尺半乘一英尺半。致罗曼·马尔斯。当我联系大芬的一家画廊，请他们创作一些真正荒诞的东西时。这是我拿着麦克风的照片。这是一幅由我老板在员工静修时唱卡拉OK的场景制成的油画。他们真的做到了。老实说，每一分钱都花得值。这才是真正的艺术。
Vivian comes back to tell me about a curious byproduct of China's rapid urbanization villages in the middle of the city. After this. So I'm back with Vivian Light. Hey Vivian. Hey Roman, how are you doing? How's the painting? Where'd you put it? It is, it is in the closet. We have this walking closet.
薇薇安回来向我讲述了中国快速城市化带来的一个奇特副产品——城中村。广告之后见。所以我和薇薇安·莱伊回来了。嘿，薇薇安。嘿，罗曼，你好吗？画怎么样？你把它挂哪儿了？它在，它在衣柜里。我们有这样一个步入式衣柜。
It's on joy side. So like when she's getting ready in the morning, there's just like this oil thing, you know, me, like, crooning at her, you know, and it's so it's this kind of funny inside joke for us. But every once in a while, if somebody's like, I don't know, coming by and they haven't been to the house because people haven't been to the house very much. So you give them a tour or whatever. And then you realize that there's this oil painting of your own face. Like in the closet and they kind of walk away.
它在欢乐的一侧。所以当她早上在准备时，就会有这样一幅油画，你知道，我，像是在对她深情吟唱，你知道，所以这对我们来说是一个非常有趣的内部笑话。但每隔一段时间，如果有人，我不知道，顺道来访，而他们以前没来过这个家里，因为人们没怎么来过这个家里。所以你带他们参观或者什么的。然后你意识到你自己的脸上有一幅油画。就像在衣柜里一样，他们有点走开了。
Yeah, man, this, Romans really entered his megalomaniac phase, I guess. He's got this painting of his face. Yeah, it freaks out the kids a little bit. It has a very fun effect on the household. I'm very happy with it. So I'm assuming you don't want to just talk about the oil painting of my face in the house. There's something that you research that didn't make it into the story.
是的，伙计，罗曼真的进入了他的自大狂阶段，我想。他有这幅他脸上的画。是的，这把孩子们吓坏了。它对家里产生了非常有趣的效果。我对此非常高兴。所以我假设你不仅仅想谈论家里我脸上的那幅油画。你研究过的一些东西没有放进这个故事里。
Yes, yes. You monsters actually cut it out of the script. But I really wanted to talk about urban villages. This thing called urban villages because Duffen is sort of both a good and a bad example of one. So what exactly is an urban village? Yeah, so they're this very fascinating urban design phenomenon that came out of the rapid development of Shenzhen. So this also happens outside of Shenzhen, but I'm just going to focus there because we're already there. If you're to look at Shenzhen today, it is a gigantic, mega-city full of towering skyscrapers,
是的，是的。你们这些怪兽实际上把它从剧本里剪掉了。但我真的很想谈谈城中村。这个叫城中村的东西，因为大芬可以说是其中的一个好例子，也是一个坏例子。那么究竟什么是城中村呢？是的，所以它们是深圳快速发展产生的一个非常迷人的城市设计现象。所以这在深圳之外也会发生，但我只关注那里，因为我们已经在那里了。如果你今天看深圳，它是一个巨大的、充满摩天大楼的特大城市，
technology parks, and these big, open city blocks that were centrally planned and are managed by the government. For the most part, it looks like this cohesive, even futuristic metropolis. I've actually dropped a photo below to give you an idea of what it looks like from. Yeah, I mean, it's amazing. Like multi-colored fancy glass.
科技园区，以及这些由政府统一规划和管理的开阔城市街区。大部分情况下，它看起来像这个凝聚力强、甚至具有未来感的都市。我实际上在下面放了一张照片，让你对它的外观有个概念。是的，我的意思是，这太棒了。就像多色绚丽的玻璃。
It looks like a future city. Yeah, exactly. But when I say that it's cohesive for the most part, it's because scattered throughout the city are these small pockets of neighborhoods that actually disrupt the urban fabric of modern Shenzhen in this really interesting way and these neighborhoods are the urban villages. So what do you mean by disrupt? Like what do they look like? So there are essentially these blocks within the city that develop
它看起来像一座未来的城市。是的，完全正确。但当我说它在很大程度上具有凝聚力时，那是因为散落在这个城市各处的是一小片一小片社区，它们以这种非常有趣的方式打破了现代深圳的城市肌理，而这些社区就是城中村。那你所说的打破是什么意思？它们看起来像什么？所以它们本质上是城市中的这些街区，它们的开发
entirely differently from the rest of centrally planned Shenzhen. Like, I mentioned that most of the city is composed of giant steel and glass skyscrapers that seem super modern with these wide streets. But urban villages are these incredibly dense neighborhoods packed with multi-story apartment buildings divided by very narrow alleyways. And you can instantly tell that the same building codes do not apply in these places as the rest of Shenzhen, because the apartment buildings, they're way smaller, like, three to 10 stories tall. But they're just so densely built next to each other. Like, they're so densely packed that they're actually called handshake buildings, because supposedly,
与其余经过统一规划的深圳截然不同。比如，我提到大部分城市由巨大的钢铁和玻璃摩天大楼组成，看起来超级现代，有着宽阔的街道。但城中村是这些令人难以置信的密集社区，挤满了多层公寓楼，被非常狭窄的小巷隔开。你可以马上看出，这些地方不适用与深圳其他地方相同的建筑规范，因为公寓楼要小得多，比如三到十层楼高。但它们彼此靠得非常紧密。它们是如此密集地挤在一起，以至于它们实际上被称为握手楼，因为据称，
you could reach your arm out the window and shake the hand of the person in the next building. Whoa, okay, you're talking very, very close. Yes, very, very close together. So these apartments are also mixed used so people might live in the floors above and then down below, it's like bustling with markets and shops and restaurants and schools. And I actually have another picture
你可以把手臂伸出窗户，与隔壁大楼里的人握手。哇，好吧，你说得非常非常近。是的，非常非常近。所以这些公寓也是混合用途的，人们可能住在上面的楼层，而在楼下，则充斥着热闹的市场、商店、餐馆和学校。我实际上还有另一张照片
of the meeting point between an urban village and the rest of the city. Okay, so we're looking at a sort of top down view of, you know, buildings surrounding, like tall buildings surrounding and then a real, like, Mishmash, Hodgepodge of buildings at different ankles and different heights. And it's, it really is very, very different. It's just like this informal enclave, like, enveloped by, you know, square angle rest of the city. So you mentioned that the building codes are different. I mean,
城市村庄与城市其余部分交汇点。好的，所以我们看到的是一种俯视视角，你知道的，周围都是高楼大厦，然后真的是那种错综复杂、大杂烩的建筑，有着不同的角度和不同的高度。而且它确实非常非常不同。它就像是一个非正式的飞地，被城市里方方正正的其他部分所包围。所以你提到建筑规范是不同的，我是说，
are they just regulated completely differently than the rest of Shenzhen? Yeah. So while most of Shenzhen is managed by the government, these urban villages are owned and managed by village collectives, which is why, you know, the same building codes don't apply to them, and why their development almost looks improvisational compared to the rest of the city. So if the rest of Shenzhen was so meticulously planned, how did urban villages, you know, come about? If you were to go back to the creation of the Shenzhen special economics zone in 1980, you know, Shenzhen was chosen as a location for a number of reasons, but a key reason was because it was this very rural area with a lot of farmland prior to the 1980s. So it was much more sparsely populated, but there were still tens of thousands of people
它们的监管方式与深圳其他地方完全不同吗？是的。因此，虽然深圳大部分地区由政府管理，但这些城中村是由村集体所有和管理的，这就是为什么同样的建筑规范不适用于它们，以及为什么与城市其他地方相比，它们的发展看起来几乎是即兴的。那么，如果深圳其他地方的规划如此一丝不苟，城中村又是怎么出现的呢？如果你回到1980年深圳经济特区建立的时候，你知道的，深圳被选为地点有很多原因，但一个关键原因是，在20世纪80年代之前，它是一个拥有大量农田的非常农村的地区。所以它的人口要稀少得多，但仍然有数万人
who lived there prior to the SEZ. These are people that we call original villagers. And it's kind of interesting because people tend to hype up the idea that Shenzhen was built from nothing and it was this blank slate prior to Shenzhen S.E.Z. And it's spring forth because of capitalism or whatever. But the presence of the original villagers actually had this huge impact on the development
在特区成立之前就住在那里。这些人就是我们所说的原村民。这挺有意思的，因为人们往往会夸大这样一种观点，即深圳是从无到有建立起来的，在深圳特区之前，这里是一张白纸。它是由于资本主义或其他原因而蓬勃发展的。但原村民的存在实际上对特区的发展产生了巨大的影响
of the S.E.Z. In what way did they have an impact? When Shenzhen was selected as a location of the first SEZ, the government bought up all of that vast uninhabited farmland, but it did not purchase the plots of land that the original villagers actually built their homes on, meaning the actual village community land where the houses were.
特区。他们在哪些方面产生了影响？当深圳被选为第一个特区所在地时，政府买下了所有那些广阔的无人居住的农田，但它并没有买下原村民实际建造房屋的土地，也就是房屋所在的实际村庄社区土地。
Oh, why not? It seems like that's the thing you do. Yeah, like apparently it was just like too expensive to buy that land and relocate the actual people. So the government just let them stay and manage those plots of lands themselves and then built the rest of Shenzhen around these villages. So these villages literally became surrounded by skyscrapers. Oh, okay. So they really predate everything and they just built around them. Which is actually like, I don't know, it's kind of a good sign.
哦，为什么不呢？这似乎是你会做的事。是的，显然买下这些土地并重新安置实际人员的成本太高了。所以政府只是让他们留下来，自己管理那些土地，然后围绕着这些村庄建造了深圳的其余部分。所以这些村庄真的被摩天大楼包围了。哦，好吧。所以它们确实比其他一切都存在得早，而城市只是围绕着它们建造的。这其实就像，我不知道，这算是一个好迹象。
They didn't just move them in Balthosam. And so much of world history is built on that premise that it's kind of a nice, I don't know, change of pace. Yeah, it's shockingly nice. It's surprising. Yeah. Just given pace. Yeah, it's shockingly nice. It's surprising. Yeah. Just given history. Yeah.
他们没有直接把它们搬走。而且世界历史上有那么多东西都建立在这个前提之上，这算是一个不错的生活节奏变化吧。是的，好得令人震惊。这很令人惊讶。是的。仅就节奏而言。是的，好得令人震惊。这很令人惊讶。是的。仅就历史而言。是的。
So how did these urban villages grow to what they look like today? Because I can't imagine the original houses and villages that used to occupy this space look like this. I mean, they look like urbanized areas. They just look like a different kind of urbanization than the skyscrapers around them. Yes, exactly. So, you know, the original villagers, they didn't have this farmland to make a living off anymore
那么这些城中村是怎么发展成今天这个样子的呢？因为我无法想象过去占据这个空间的原始房屋和村庄是这个样子的。我的意思是，它们看起来像城市化地区。它们只是看起来与周围的摩天大楼是另一种不同的城市化。是的，完全正确。所以，你知道的，原村民，他们不再有这些农田来谋生了
after the creation of the SEC. But there was this huge opportunity because they had their hands on this prime real estate that was in the middle of a very rapidly growing city. So, with the original villagers ended up doing, as they formed village collectives to manage the land, and then they tore down their houses that were there
特区成立之后。但这是一个巨大的机会，因为他们手里掌握着一块黄金地段，位于一个迅速发展的城市的正中间。因此，原村民最终做的是，他们成立了村集体来管理土地，然后拆除了那里的房屋
and then constructed these really dense multi-story apartment buildings to run out to like the millions of new migrants that were flocking to Shenzhen for job opportunities. Wow, so they really just bought into the whole, like we're gonna become a capitalist economy, right? Yeah, they just leaned right into it. Okay, good for them.
然后建造了这些非常密集的 多层公寓楼，出租给成千上万涌入深圳寻找工作机会的新移民。哇，所以他们真的完全接受了“我们要成为一个资本主义经济体”的理念，对吧？是的，他们顺应了潮流。好吧，这很好。
Yeah, but like the remarkable thing about urban villages is that you know, especially they only make up a small part of the city, but by the year 2000, they housed essentially half of the population of Shenzhen. Oh my God, that doesn't compute from the pictures I see. Yeah. That's really, really insane. So these are really desks, like people are really packed on top of each other.
是的，但是关于城中村，最引人注目的事情是，你知道，特别是它们只占城市的一小部分，但到2000年，它们基本上容纳了深圳一半的人口。哦，天哪，从我看到的照片来看，这无法理解。是的。这真的太疯狂了。所以这些地方真的很密集，人们真的挤在一起。
And it makes it seem like also that those buildings surrounding these urban villages are not very desks. Like they don't have enough housing for people. Yeah, exactly. So urban villages basically became some of the only affordable housing options for a lot of migrant workers in Shenzhen. So, you know, for a lot of new low income residents, you have students, restaurant workers, construction workers, factory workers, basically blue collar workers. Urban villages are the first stops
而且这也让人觉得，环绕这些城中村的那些建筑其实并不那么密集。好像他们没有足够的住房给人们。是的，完全一样。因此，城中村基本上成了深圳许多外来务工人员仅有的负担得起的住房选择之一。所以，你知道的，对于许多低收入的新居民来说，有学生、餐馆工人、建筑工人、工厂工人，基本上是蓝领工人。城中村是第一站
when trying to find housing in Shenzhen because it's a very expensive city. And because you could find all of these different types of people and different types of shops and resources condensed into one small area. Urban villages are full of life and really have become the center of a lot of culture. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, nothing is more dead than some dumb business district. Tall buildings, right? Yeah, yeah. So, you know, earlier, when I said that
在深圳找房子的时候，因为这是一个非常昂贵的城市。而且因为你可以在一个狭小的区域内找到所有这些不同类型的人、不同类型的商店和资源。城中村充满了生机，确实成为了许多文化的中心。是的，这说得通。我的意思是，没有什么比一些无聊的商业区更死气沉沉的了。高楼大厦，对吧？是的，是的。所以，你知道的，早些时候，当我这么说的时候
Duffen is a good and a bad example of an urban village. It's a good example because it's a similarly dense multi-use neighborhood that developed in this very different way from the rest of Shenzhen. But it's also a bad example because Duffen was a place that was given a lot of special treatment and attention by the government because it already had this flourishing painting industry. So, Duffen was allocated money to modernize its infrastructure, but urban villages on the whole are not places that get a lot of respect.
大芬是城中村的一个好例子，也是一个坏例子。这是一个很好的例子，因为它是一个类似密集的、多功能的社区，其发展方式与深圳其他地方截然不同。但这也是一个坏例子，因为大芬是一个受到政府大量特殊对待和关注的地方，因为它已经拥有了这个蓬勃发展的绘画产业。因此，大芬获得了现代化基础设施的资金，但总的来说，城中村并不是一个受到很多尊重的地方。
And what do you mean by that? So, because these are spaces that are accessible to the poor, urban villages are often associated with, you know, overcrowding, shoddy construction. They're also linked with drug use and seen as dangerous areas. Of course, it's been debated how much of that reputation is just classism. So urban villages, especially in the last couple decades, have been targeted for quote, urban
你这是什么意思？所以，因为这些是对穷人开放的空间，城中村经常与拥挤、劣质建筑联系在一起。它们还与吸毒联系在一起，被视为危险地区。当然，这种声誉有多少只是阶级主义，一直存在争议。所以城中村，尤其是在过去几十年里，一直是所谓的城市“更新”的目标。
renewal. And a lot of them have been torn down and redeveloped into more modern housing that more closely fits into that master plan for the rest of the city. But when urban villages get demolished, like hundreds of thousands of people get displaced from their homes. Yeah, I definitely can recognize that maybe urban villages have their problems, but not having affordable housing in the center of large city
而且许多建筑被拆除并重新开发成更现代的住宅，更贴合深圳其他地区的总体规划。但当城中村被拆迁时，成千上万的人无家可归。是的，我完全承认城中村可能存在问题，但大城市中心没有经济实用的住房
is a problem that all cities seem to have. Like they just seem to push low wage workers that work in the city and serve people's needs further and further away and have to commute. And it just makes life harder for the people that we rely on. These people that we call essential workers at this point, because of the pandemic, it's just, it's really awful to see that happen everywhere. Yeah, yeah, that's totally right. And, you know, I think it's really important. In the case of urban villages, it's really important to understand how important they've been to Shenzhen's success. I spoke with a professor of architecture and urban design named Jean-Dou,
这是所有城市似乎都存在的问题。就像他们只是把在城市工作、满足人们需求的低薪工人推得越来越远，让他们不得不通勤。这让那些我们赖以生存的人的生活变得更加艰难。由于疫情，这些被我们称为基本工作者的人，真的很难过看到这种事到处发生。是的，完全正确。而且，你知道的，我认为这真的很重要。在城中村的案例中，了解它们对深圳成功的重要性真的很重要。我采访了一位建筑与城市设计教授，名叫曾杜，
who actually has written extensively about Shenzhen. And you know, she said that if you were to think about it from an ecological point of view, she compared urban villages to the wetlands of the city, because they've provided all of this overlooked support to, you know, its overall health and development. Yeah, I mean, these interstitial places where people have a little bit more freedom to solve problems and create the spaces that they need to live and become like little places to experiment. There's exactly like creating a healthy ecology with lots of different, like Nietzsche's
她实际上写了大量关于深圳的文章。你知道的，她说，如果你从生态学的角度来考虑，她把城中村比作城市的湿地，因为它们为城市的整体健康和发展提供了所有这些被忽视的支持。是的，我的意思是，这些人们有更多自由去解决问题、创造他们需要的生活空间的中间地带，变成了像小实验室一样的地方。这完全就像创造了一个拥有许多不同生态位的健康生态系统
being fulfilled and represented. I mean, not everyone can live in a gleaming downtown skyscraper. Yeah, totally. We know that. Yeah, I know that firsthand. Well, this is fascinating stuff. I mean, I just, I'm so intrigued by these places,
得到满足和代表。我的意思是，并不是每个人都能住在闪闪发光的市中心摩天大楼里。是的，完全可以。我们知道这一点。是的，我对此有着切身体会。嗯，这真是迷人的东西。我的意思是，我只是，我对这些地方太感兴趣了，
they're very cinematic. And I think they are a little odd to us in different ways, but they serve this vital purpose of figuring out how people actually need to live. And it's important to pay attention to what services they provide. But it's a fascinating space. I'd love to hear more about them. I can't believe us monsters told you not to talk about it. I see.
它们非常具有电影感。而且我认为它们在不同方面对我们来说有点奇怪，但它们发挥了弄清楚人们实际需要如何生活这一至关重要的目的。关注它们提供什么服务是很重要的。但这是一个引人入胜的空间。我很想听到更多关于它们的信息。我简直不敢相信我们这些怪物叫你别谈论它。我明白了。
I knew it. No, it's super fascinating stuff. Well, thanks for bringing this little extra information to us. I really appreciate it. And thank you for letting me rent about it. 99% invisible was produced this week by Vivian Le. Edited by Emmith Fitzgerald.
我早就知道了。不，这超级迷人。好吧，谢谢你给我们带来这小块额外的信息。我真的很感激。也谢谢你让我对此大发牢骚。本周的《99%无形》由Vivian Le制作。Emmith Fitzgerald编辑。
Mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, fact checking by Graham Haysha, music by a director of Sound Swan Rihout with additional music by Jenny Conley-Driesos, John Newfeld and Nate Query. The Lennie Hall is the executive producer Kurt Colestay is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Ruppe, Jason Dalyone, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Lose We and Joanne Du,
技术制作由Martin Gonzales混合，事实核查由Graham Haysha完成，音乐由声音总监Swan Rihout创作，附加音乐由Jenny Conley-Driesos、John Newfeld和Nate Query提供。Lennie Hall是执行制片人，Kurt Colestay是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Christopher Johnson、Lashemadon、Joe Rosenberg、Christopher Ruppe、Jason Dalyone、Sophia Klatsker，还有我Roman Mars。本周特别感谢Lose We和Joanne Du，
whose interviews did not make it into the piece, but if you want to read more about the complexities of Shen Zhen's special economic zone, Joanne wrote a great book about it called the Shen Zhen Experiment, the story of China's instant city, you should check it out. We are part of the Stitcher and serious XM podcast family. Now, it had quartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and
他们的采访没有被剪辑到节目中，但如果你想了解更多关于深圳经济特区复杂性的信息，Joanne写了一本关于它的好书，名叫《深圳实验：中国即时城市的故事情节》，你应该去看看。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在，它总部设在加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的住宅区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区，
beautiful uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99 PI or we're on Instagram and read it to you can find links to other stature shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI, and also pictures of that creepy oil painting that Viv had commissioned up my face at 99PI.org. The End Look out on a serious ex a day The thighs that no darkness in my soul Shadows on the hill The sketched trees and down the hills There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars或@99 PI找到我，或者我们在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI的每一期往期节目，还有Viv委托制作的挂在我脸上的那幅诡异油画的照片，网址是99PI.org。结束。看外面黑暗不在我心中。山上的阴影。素描的树木和山下。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。